so my name is mordechai i'm a tech lead
at iron skills
and i'm gonna give my talk about uh
real-time phishing attacks and uh
or real-time data enrichment and
real-time data pipelines for detecting
phishing attacks
so what is phishing
okay so i can try to explain what's on
the screen listeners um
the idea here is that
we have a email and it's uh being sent
from
no reply at
liblibeats.co.uk
and the subject is
ayal your email has your email password
has expired so please log in
and um
change your change your password
um
well this this is a problem because uh
this isn't actually an email from
microsoft this is an email from
uh
no reply and libyans
so this is a one example of an email
that we're trying to detect
uh here's another one uh
do you have a free amendment to talk so
this one's a little bit more complicated
the idea here is that
it's not really a link that you're
supposed to click on it's a kind of
generic message and we're trying to
also detect emails that don't have like
a clearly defined thread
so how do we do this
well using big data
one of our advantages is that one of our
advantages and challenges is that we
have a lot of emails and a lot of data
to go through
so
at iron scales we have around 1 million
in protected mailboxes 100 million
inspections you
inspected emails per day
and if you calculate that in the average
email size we actually
ingest petabytes of email emails per
month and so that works out to be many
thousands of email inspections per
second and many tens of thousands of
predictions per second because we make
many different predictions for a
specific email
and also that this is a challenge
because our systems are constantly
growing
how many duplicates do you have
duplicates like this the
same email
yeah that's a good question so one of
the things that we do is try to cluster
or identify if an email is similar to
another i don't have the exact numbers
of
what kind of email is duplicated but we
do
do something called like we cluster so
example for a specific company if we see
the same email multiple times to
multiple users we'll cluster them
together and if it's for a different
company create a new incident for that
company because i had a fishing that
and friend of mine got the same with
different names
yeah so it's a good point so many of
these attacks come from a single server
from using a specific template or they
may come from different servers using
the same template so
it's kind of the challenge here
all right so
um what i want to focus here is on email
context
so
when we're looking at an email we have
some type of metadata we have let's say
the ip address
here in this example at 69 420 we have
let's say the domain example.com and the
sender name
john doe
does that mean that the email is
phishing it's not enough data
um just an ip address like a ip address
isn't enough to make a classification
so we tried to get the context of that
ip address
so here we can see that this ip has been
seen 10 times
out of those 10 times seven of the times
it's already been marked as phishing and
so therefore
70 of the attacks
or the emails have been marked as
fishing and that's pretty suspicious any
new email from that ip
might
looks probably also phishing
um so this is the idea of ip reputation
um so basically we have like a pipeline
that goes through and inspects every
email that we receive in real time
there's three steps one extract features
two run a prediction three save the
results and we can use those results to
make new predictions in the future
so
what does that look like for the scope
of ip reputation
so here we have some raw data coming in
let's say the ip address 69 420 once
again
we have the features that we extract
let's say
the score is 0.9 because we've seen this
email 10 times marked minus phishing
and then we mapped that prediction using
some kind of tabular data machine
learning algorithm
so here in the in this example we have
70 probability of phishing
so
at the persistence layer at the end of
the prediction we then
save those
those counts to our ip reputation
feature store
so let's say we would increment the
count so that there would be plus one
phishing plus one total
and then we can use that to classify for
their emails
um
[Music]
yeah so let me try to walk through this
again all right so we have the raw data
that's coming in um
so for example the raw data here is the
ip address which is 69 420 for example
so then we would extract the ip score
for that ip address by querying our
feature store
let's imagine that the future star
returns some results and says that
the ip score is 0.9 which means that
we've seen this ip
10 times
and out of those 10 times nine of them
are marked as vision
that's good all right so then we would
say okay well let's map that to
prediction so we send it we send it to
like uh inference they say
70
probability of phishing based on these
scores
we would then we would then save the
model or save the predictions so that we
can use it as an input for further
emails so for example if we think that
it's phishing we can say okay well
this ip is now more suspicious in the
future
does that make sense okay
all right so how do we do this in real
time
so imagine for a second we have a
feature store so we have basically a
class with two methods something like
that get reputation which um
like you give it a string and return
some kind of flow uh the reputation of
that ip address and then increment
which um
change which adds like new counts to the
to the table so we have um let's say
fishing plus one total plus one
and then we can use this
uh to make predictions
so we would then save that to let's say
a postgres table with four columns
ipv value which is the ip address and
then phishing count spam count and total
account
or not
there's a problem with this approach and
the amount of data that we address so if
we're talking about 5000 emails per
second maybe
inserting one at a time into a
relational database is not the best
approach
so we need to do it a little faster
so maybe we can use a patching strategy
so instead of for every email we send it
directly to the database we put it into
redis
and then every one every one minute we
pull out the
records from redis and insert them into
the table
but if you do the math this is also
problematic we have let's say 5000
emails per second 60 seconds so we have
300 000 record changes for a single
minute
um this is problematic even even more
because we have many different fields
that we're trying to rebuke for example
the sender name uh the domain stuff like
that
so this approach is also not good enough
um
so we need something a little faster
um
at iron skills one of the
solutions that we use is cassandra so we
take the worker sends uh
the insert to a cassandra
um which is divided into multiple
partitions or cassandra they're called v
notes
and then the idea is that
once they're in cassandra they're split
into multiple different surfers and so
that
there isn't a bottleneck on a specific
area so this is like the idea of the
cassandra so it's much faster
so
what does that mean for our inspection
pipeline as a whole
ip reputation is one part of
our machine learning system and we like
to divide that into two categories
primary detectors which we'll detect in
email based on there's no context
involved it's just using like templates
or some
basic fact about the email then we have
generalizers which use
the predictions from the first model and
try to extend them to other ones this is
for example classifying
based on clustering so is this email
similar to another email that we also
marked as vision
the most important metric that we use is
precision because we want all of our
models to
um
not detect any false messages
if you want to do some clustering
okay yeah so two metrics you need to to
imagine to see how far they are right so
there's many different ways that we
could say that emails are far apart one
of them would be let's say based on the
body
so let's say if there's textual
similarity
and we use some normalization so that
emails like say
are similar and then we would strip the
like special characters and match them
for example if there's uh the name of
the recipient in the email then we'd
strip that and then try to match them
this is actually
might be considered a type of clustering
because we're trying to identify the ip
address and if the ip address is common
between twenty two emails
we can then match them and say that
they're both fishing
the idea of the primary detectors
is that um
they're very high precision and there's
low dependencies for example if we have
a nlp model that's trying to detect a
specific template
then we don't need the context or the
reputation of some type of metadata in
order to make this classification
um another example would be let's say
image classification if we have a link
the link goes to a landing page which is
a fake fake login for some let's say
fake microsoft login page then we can
know that without understanding the
reputation
of the sender
but there's some disadvantages with this
approach because these models are slow
to retrain they can't respond in real
time to new types of templates or
attacks and they have low recall because
it's not possible for these types of
models to know every single template in
existence and new templates are being
created all the time
so that's where generalizer is working
the idea is that we can increase the
recall and respond to new types of
attacks in real time by instead of using
the template we use like the metadata
and associate emails with each other
based on some kind of similarity for
example ip reputation
if it's uh sent from the same ip then
it's also probably phishing
but the the con is that it depends on
the existing detectors
like the template model in order to make
the first prediction
the other thing is that it's difficult
to calibrate because
the email
right so we have some score let's say
the email is detected 50 from this ip
does that mean that there's an 80 chance
of being phishing 90 chance
so that's a little difficult to
determine and it might change based on
improvements upstream and other
classifiers
um so yeah that's kind of uh the idea
so
some of the stuff we discussed there's
many types of phishing
we use contextual data to enrich
enrich our feature set and we can build
real-time pipelines
from their context and scale them and
then build like stack multiple models
and pipelines to build a robust system
yes
[Music]
all right and um of course we are hiring
so if you are a data engineer
a back end or an ml engineer an ml
product manager or just a smart person
some useful skills
we would love to have you and
build awesome software together
privacy issues because
what you describe right right you can do
analyze analysis
in the text right and many cases
the privacy
prevents you
okay yeah so that's a good question so
one of the things that we do is um
obviously we suck to comply and you know
we have other licenses one of the things
we do is we tokenize all of the emails
and then we use like a hash tokenizer so
instead of um the word manager it would
be like um some kind of uh
number
and then we can analyze it
using that way
any other questions yeah yeah so what
did we like in the
mix picture of the approaches between
you know more static matching of ips or
domains or hosts or so on versus you
know content based on some of the mvp
and the images like how much
can you say you know it's like 70 30 10
90.
that's a good question um i can say that
right now um let's say primary detectors
make up
well first of all there's some overlap
so many of our machine learning models
will detect
um the same email and some of them won't
detect it only one will detect it but we
could split it let's say
50 50 or something like that between
generalizers and the primary detectors
roughly
can you see how much like your models i
mean a lot of what you should is
basically given that an
email the name
is like sending out phishing then you
know identify it rapidly and well to
what degree do the models work well for
identifying you know a phishing you know
for the content rate but this is the
phishing email even if someone was
sending out a different
one guy was writing a different template
and sending it out from a different ip
for every different person how well
would the models work for that you know
more of a cold stuff what you could say
yeah so first of all we have records of
all of the templates or many templates
that are common to phishing um but for
example sometimes we have targeted
attacks where they have a specially
crafted email that this
that they send to a specific person um
let's say a vip at a company um
one of the things that we see for
example is that they'll send
like a very generic request like hey um
i need to chat can you can you send me a
phone number or something like that um
and then we have like some type of
reputation based
system so we can say okay well the
sender is being very
very um
this sender is trying to be very close
to the
sender but
there's no prior history so we can try
to analyze it based on
reputation like that
how do you trade any
tool of real time like how
i start screening like for the feature
store
okay yeah so um our messaging queues are
right now rabbit mq but we're switching
over to kafka
in terms of real-time data stores mainly
we use cassandra for
persistence and stuff like that
and
i'm interested to know
and
i think that
some employees and specific companies
are more grown to receive
maliciously
okay did you
did you try to detect some kind of
titles and say that i won't pronounce
actually yes so we have something called
the vip production so we have a special
tag that we assign to people with titles
like ceo cfo stuff like that and then we
have a much lower confidence much lower
threshold for escalating those types of
attacks
um
higher higher false positives but the
idea is that these are higher impact so
we'll be more careful there
when scaling how do you know you're
being resourceful enough like when you
say it's enough optimizing but
so that's a good question basically
we're in growth mode so you know it's
just like turn on another server we
don't attempt optimize
but one of the big
initiatives right now is moving to
kubernetes and setting up auto scaling
so that's going to reduce our
computer
um any other questions
you said that the clustering is like
high level low precision isn't it the
other way around i mean campaign
matching is high decision no recall
i'm sorry can you set up the approach to
use was it said that your normal nlp
model was basically customing a template
matching but and you said that that's
high precision low uh high unique or low
precision but isn't that approach high
precision low recall you're checking if
it's similar to something to an existing
template so it works well for known
positives but not for normal positives
yeah so um template matching uh is high
precision load recall
no the one after that okay
yeah so like for example here we're
looking at a specific template and we
know that okay the content of this
template is phishing and so if we detect
that this template is in the email then
it's also phishing
but here if we look at for example an ip
based feature then it doesn't
necessarily mean the email is phishing
let me give you an example suppose that
the ip address is a google server
ib address is google server sending out
to
many different you know millions of
people some of those emails are phishing
um but the majority are not so there
could be some confusion there
all right well thanks guys